hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday night yeah is it too bright in
here is it fine is it good looks looks
good I didn't touch anything so don't
look at me looks good okay that's good
trying to figure it out if things all
right yeah I mean it looks fine to me
you know what saying hey everybody
what's going on so uh we're doing
another thing like we did last Monday
because we um bought the thing with the
both The Haunting pilots on there from
2002 um somebody had the idea I think it
was you Danny to do to talk about the
actual pilot show and then also the
Hollywood movie that was based on it so
we did that last week with Haunting in
Connecticut so this week we're doing uh
Haunting in Georgia Georgia and
comparing and contrasting it with The
Haunting in Connecticut 2 colon ghosts
of Georgia yeah which why on Earth did
they call it that because the second
movie has nothing to do with the first
movie they're two completely different
cases I know they were kind of trying to
tie it in it's like it's a sequel but
it's not and it just made the title of
the second one just seem like really
clunky to me Haunting in Connecticut
except it's in Georgia and doesn't have
anything to do with Connecticut I don't
know they just wanted the people saw the
first one to see the second one yeah cuz
it was the same production company stuff
not the same director um but yeah it was
the same production company going to say
like Danny said uh the TV version is
more of a documentary The Hollywood
version is a straight up horror film
both good flicks he says uh Hollywood
version of this is a little bit better
than haunting a Connecticut Hollywood
version in my opinion only because it
sort of turns into House of Wax 05 which
is awesome um I'm going to say I think
out of the two movies I liked Haunting
in Connecticut a lot better yeah I think
the acting was a lot better um the
storytelling was a lot better this one
was okay like the acting was okay but it
seemed a
little pretty standard to me well it got
a little uh repetitive I feel like it
didn't really like it kind of Spun its
wheels for a long time which I'll kind
of get into in a little bit and just
like Haunting in Connecticut it went
wildly off of the real uh story but you
know I guess the first one did that too
so what are you gonna do about it yeah
but it didn't even pretend to uh follow
the the Georgia case now it did you know
yeah got Mr Gordy in it but it has their
own take of Mr about it yeah and uh
that's about it the little girls look
kind of the same but other than that I
really couldn't follow the the Hollywood
movie too much it was just too uh I just
couldn't get into it I couldn't get into
it I was having a hard time and the
weird thing about it is that when we
were watching it um I had thought that I
had never seen it before but we we were
watching I'm like wow this is really
familiar like some of this stuff so I
must have watched it at some point I
don't really know why I might you know
what I might have watched it back when
we talked about uh the wreck haunting
which is what both of these were based
on like remember we did a show about it
years ago and I might have watched it
back then just for shits and giggles
like to see what was going on but
because I know I've seen it before but
yeah I don't love it I didn't love this
one like I said the acting is fine
there's like some good actors in it um
but I just felt like the the
storytelling was wasn't real like
compelling you know what I mean and so
it I kind of found my attention
wandering uh a lot which doesn't usually
happen when I watch movies I'm usually
real attentive but this one I was just
kind of like what kind of looking at my
phone and stuff which I don't usually do
so now the haunting series that the uh
the Georgia case is one of the pilot
episodes it's it's movie length but it's
a
documentary and if you just take if you
just take the documentary at face value
it seems to be one of the most
compelling cases in the entire series
because there's a well-known
parapsychologist involved there's a lot
of witnesses of this from this family
involved um but I don't know what the
truth of the case is I don't know if
anybody else has actually
verified it's mostly just going by what
people say say they saw them say what
they heard there's not a lot of
physicality to this case it's
basically girl sees ghosts he keep she
keeps seeing ghosts and turns out people
know the ghosts that she's talking about
she can she could even pick them out out
of a
lineup um other than that it's not all
that physical there's not a lot of
physical manifestations that I remember
yeah it's not a lot of stuff like
Poltergeist activity or anything like
that it's mostly Apparition apparitions
which yeah is is subjective so I kind of
get why some stuff but the thing about
it and I had forgotten this because they
didn't do this in The Haunting in
Connecticut pilot did they where this
one I'm we're watching it I wasn't drunk
or anything we were watching it not yet
anyway but um so we're watching it and I
was like wow the actress they got to
play the mom looks just like her and
then I was like oh it is her yeah they
actually got the actual people to
reenact everything yeah which they never
they didn't do that in the haunting and
Connecticut did they no and they didn't
do that subsequently they didn't do that
in the series in the series either so
it's like that I thought maybe that was
just they were trying it out to see if
it would work cuz I'm like wow they they
really like nailed that and then I was
like oh that is her must have been more
than one production team working at
different places at different times and
in this particular one they had all the
witnesses and they were willing to
reenact it so that's what they
did and I thought honestly for Not
actors I thought they did a pretty good
job job you know what I mean and they
got and it looks like they got everybody
like the actual people to reprise their
roles in the real life drama you know
and they are southern as [__] oh my
goodness the accents man I was going oh
yeah yeah we were doing the the whole
time yeah reminds me of Mississippi I
forget what they sound like until I hear
it again like they were kind of period
accents from the you know 90s 80s and
90s because it does change over time
yeah but uh yeah because like you young
people in Mississippi don't quite sound
like people that you know grew up in the
80s there things morph because of the
effects of cable TV you know had a lot
to do with it but uh yeah handed holler
yeah something like that okay yeah hated
holler I mean yeah just like every time
somebody said something it's like it
just tickled the [__] out of us yeah cuz
it's like well it's kind of sounded like
my dad's side of the family they're not
from Georgia they're from Tennessee
which is close enough and some of my
dad's TI of family s it sounded like
that yeah so like had thick accents like
that so it's just kind of like
Mississippi Alabama sound identical yeah
identical there are differences between
Mississippi and Georgia
but a lot of it is real familiar they
say things the same way we would say
things yeah um but you know just
funny funny to hear it
see Danny Ring's talking about uh Katie
saakov who was the redheaded she played
the ant in the Hollywood version of this
which you recognized from um Battlestar
Galactica yeah uh said also also yeah
that's right and uh she was also in
Halloween resurrection he said and in
White Noise too yeah I remember not
loving White noise too I like the first
one was pretty good but I don't the
second one I remember not making much of
an impression but I I'll give it another
guy one of these days she she is yeah I
really liked her character in the in the
um she's still in real good shape too I
think she's my age I think she's about
50 maybe coming up on 50 probably a
couple years younger the movie um you
know the Hollywood version of the that
that came out in 2013 so it's 10 years
old so however she was 10 years younger
in this movie than she is now you know
what I mean yeah Samantha points out the
mom and her sister were from a place
called called haed holler yeah haed
holler yeah haed holler yeah or haunted
hollow as normal people would say and I
think that like she even says that like
the lady says that we called it haed
haror some people call that haunted
hollow they were so cute yeah they were
so cute I thought they were like really
funny yeah yeah Danny said I like the
way the real mother says her husband's
name like Andy yeah he Andy was adding a
couple syllables yeah there yeah it was
several well I kind of feel the Southern
Accents in general do that it's like you
know it's like a one or two syllable
word and it has like five or six
syllables you know and there's also
stretch it
out real hardcore Southern Accents
Mississippi Alabama they're
gendered the accent that women used were
was a little bit different than the the
accent that men used and the tone female
tone usually especially you know that
they grew up in the 80s and probably a
little bit before high pitched and honic
they're at the edge of laughing or
becoming hysterical at any time oh I
can't do it I can't do it my voice can't
go up that high but there're just you're
not woman enough is not enough woman
it's
just yeah and they all sound like they
12 sound like 12y old girls just
twittering and just laughing
constantly y'all got that recipe for
but yeah I probably can't do it either
my voice isn't that my cousins just
couldn't shut up my female cousin could
not shut the [__] up if they were awake
they were talking it was a constant
stream of [__] chatter man especially
when they were teenagers I have a hard
time dealing shut the [__] up I have a
hard time dealing with people like that
not going they ask you three questions
before you had time to answer it little
Tommy do you like going out at all do
you just stay everyone just keep on
going you never get a chance to ask her
do you like going out or you like
staying home or you like going to the
movies or do you like to or do you like
to cuz it called me Little Tommy Little
Tommy yeah cuz my dad was was also Tom
cuz his dad's name is Tom rossor they
always call the or Little
Tommy yeah W cat said that's why I
always hung out with dudes more yeah you
know I had a lot of female friends too
and still do but um I I don't know I
kind of find found dudes like kind of
easier to deal with like back then I
guess CU they weren't always at the edge
of [__] hysteria yeah it was it was
that kind of thing yeah and I was just
other women were like that I was like sh
yeah cute but just you know yeah real
high strong like I said yeah and I just
I have a hard time like hanging around
CU I'm real I'm pretty chill and like
laidback so I can't deal with people
that are like on all the time it's like
really it's it's exhausting although the
20s roll around they're not as bad a lot
of it has to do just how young they were
yeah so I think we did a show about the
w reconning a long time ago like where
we talked about the thing but I mean
that was years ago so we'll talk about
um you know the the
episode so uh this was
actually I don't know I really likeed
this episode and I had forgotten we
hadn't watched it since we did the show
about it last time which was years ago
and I had forgotten how long of a time
span it it went over I mean it pretty
much went over until from that little
girl she was like three or four at the
beginning
until she was like a teenager right I
also forgot that cuz I remembered Mr
Gordy cuz obviously everybody's going to
remember that but I also forgot that
there was like a whole bunch of like
scary spirits too because you can't just
have one like Friendly Ghost that's not
that's no fun I could and I kind of feel
like and I'm not saying that like
they're just making it up or anything
but I'm just saying for a story to be
adapted to a haunting you can't just
have a story where it's like hey we had
this Friendly Ghost and it just did nice
[__] and so we just let it stay you know
what I mean cuz there's no conflict
there there's no drama it's not scary so
it's like even if they do have a
Friendly Ghost they always have to have
scary ones like coming in on the back of
it so I had forgotten kind of about that
aspect of it as well CU I remembered the
stuff about Mr Gordy but that was about
it so at the very beginning you have
this family like I said the wrick family
and the mom's name was Lisa right and
the dad's name was Andrew or Andy and
they have a dog named Heidi who like I
said I think she was three or four now
they moved into this house I don't know
where they moved from they were
somewhere else in Georgia I guess but
they moved into this house in 1988 and
it was in uh ellersly Georgia which I gu
like a pretty small town now they didn't
go too much into this but they did
mention on the show on the documentary
that the house had been inexplicably
abandoned by its previous owners which I
guess would was meant to imply you know
it was haunted so they got the [__] out
although they never really I mean you
know they didn't say but they just did
imply that's and they got it for cheap
because somebody just took off and left
it so there's that so not too long after
they move into the house their daughter
Heidi starts hanging out supposedly with
this old man that she sees named Mr
Gordy now at first now if you're
4-year-old daughter comes in the house
and says hey I'm hanging out with this
old man in the yard like we're playing
everybody's be like you know stranger
danger like red flag you know what I
mean I'm calling Child Protective or
whatever it's you know what I mean I'm
calling the cops and that's kind of how
the family reacted at first because they
thought this was a real dude that she
was talking about and that's super
creepy like having some old dude just
like wander into your yard and hanging
out with your four-year-old daughter you
know this is Georgia they knew of the
names of everybody who were their
neighbors so they didn't know who this
Gordy was he must have come from far
away to come hang out with the child
yeah and like I said anytime like a a
man wants to hang out with a child they
don't know that's you
know the dude went out there with a
[__] pistol looking for her dad went
out there with his well I mean you can't
blame him but I feel like 99% of dads
would do the same thing her dad grabbed
a Smith and Wesson auto pistol [__]
went out there I'm going go out there
and see what's going on with yeah but he
couldn't find anybody yeah he didn't
find anybody yeah so this kind of went
on for a little while where she just
kept saying I'm playing with Mr Gordy
and I'm doing this and that and the mom
said that it got to a point where she's
like Mr Gordy was even in her room and
she would like bring like when she would
give her like a sandwich or whatever
like she's like I went another sandwich
for Mr Gordy and she'd be like just in
there talking to a chair and [__] yeah
so after a while the mom determines well
okay so I guess this is like an
imaginary friend which you know fair
enough a lot of kids have that so it's
like at least it's not a real child
predator so that's good so this kind of
went on for a while they didn't seem
terribly worried about it they said the
only thing that was bad about this you
know neighborhood was that there weren't
any other kids in the neighborhood so
she didn't really have anybody to play
with and so they said that the fact that
she had this what they thought was an
imaginary friend was like keeping her
happy you know what I mean cuz she
seemed okay like she didn't seem
isolated or anything like that they're
like ah well it's probably harmless or
you know whatever so but they said man
she talked about this dude all the time
and they were always playing and he was
pushing her on the swing and all this
other kind of
stuff now um a couple months after this
though something else happened that was
kind of weird and maybe like a little
bit more Sinister so at this point
there's like a knock at the front door
and the little girl goes to answer it
which don't let your four-year-old kid
like just open the [__] door randomly
you know what I mean once again this is
rural Georgia yeah I mean I guess but
still it's still not a good idea
everybody knows everybody you know all
the neighbors it's safe pretty
much yeah but but you know it little
girl's until it's not well that's just
everywhere it's like that everywhere but
it's actually pretty safe out there yeah
um I'm just saying because nobody knows
where you live cuz they don't know that
place I would you never find it I
wouldn't be letting a four-year-old kid
answer the door though yeah but so she
answers the door and she said that she
saw a man standing on the porch like
outside the door that had like his hand
was all wrapped up in bandages and he
was like had blood all over his
shirt now she later said that this man
introduced himself as con con not that
kind of con I think it was Khan Co that
ended up not being his name but that's
kind of what she thought she thought he
said yeah now the hilarious thing is
that in the reenactment which was the
real people other than the little girl
obviously they had to get a um an
actress for that because the actual girl
was you know a teenager in her 20s or
whatever so the little girl just like
opens the door Sees this bloody dude
standing there and she's like like what
and then she like turns around and like
goes her mom's in the kitchen or
something and she goes in there and
she's like hey there's a bloody man at
the front door like just completely calm
got and the mom's like what yeah and
like she goes she gets a knife and she
like goes out there like what the [__]
like looking around didn't want anybody
there and there wasn't anybody there um
but you know the kid had left the door
wide open I would have thought that was
a real person and now they're inside the
house and they're going to murder us
that's what I would have thought but
apparently she didn't think that I don't
know but so she goes around and looks
and sees doesn't see anything so at this
point she's kind of like okay well this
must be another imaginary thing that the
kid is seeing just like Mr Gordy is
because at this point they had
determined oh Mr gord's probably her
imaginary friend because they never saw
him you know what I
mean now so that
happened and then not too long after
that Heidi also started
seeing some entity that she called the
dark figure she said she never saw his
face he was just like shaped like a man
but it was just like all black like a
shadow and it's like he looked like he
had like a hood or something so like she
never saw his face right she said she
saw that like all over the place um and
again they thought she was just seeing
stuff until one night she woke up and
she had scratches on her
face um and then I think like
subsequently I don't know if it was the
same night or like the next night or
something like that like the husband
Andy he also woke up and had like
scratch marks on his side like you know
what I mean like there and it was three
of them I guess so it's like that
demonic claw Mark deal although I don't
they didn't really
say they didn't say that they thought it
was demonic did they well maybe they did
later cuz they did actually kind of get
into some religious stuff later remember
exactly what they said but I don't think
that they thought it was demonic at
first you know what I'm saying I think
they just thought it was some kind of
whatever a ghost yeah
now I think like for a long time I think
that Heidi was the only person that saw
him but I think the parents did start to
think oh well maybe something weird is
going on because of
that so at this point they decide to
maybe get some help with this so they
call a very famous parapsychologist uh
Dr William g roll who if you know
anything about paranormal anything um he
wrote a [__] ton of books in the 70s CU
I remember reading a bunch of them as a
kid um pretty well respected I feel like
as far as parapsychology goes he's
German he's a German guy that St here
yeah and he's
very um real scientific scientific
minded he's not kind of like yeah he
does use psychics and things like that
but he's pretty quick to um try to find
like a rational explanation for stuff
like rather than jumping to he believes
lot ghost or whatever believes a lot of
the stuff I basically believe in um he
believes that there that that there is
paranormal I know there's paranormal
I've seen it I see it off and on even to
this day uh which if you're a regular
listener to the show you know what it is
we're talking about [__] that's happened
around here in the house he believes
it's uh mostly human generated though
through psychic abilities I agree a lot
of it is that Poltergeist is
that
but I also think there can be outside
forces because I I believe that you part
of you survives after death because I've
had near-death
experiences and I'm
so there's a
possibility that a person that is no
longer incarnated incarnated or person
who's dead I guess you can say some part
of them can interact with you
sometimes which he gets into this later
on I kind of agree with most of what he
thought it
was the family ends up going to religion
for the solution which I agree with that
too because they believed in religion
and belief and faith is very powerful um
and I think that that also helped him
you know do I think these were actual
ghost of dead people
no I think they're recorded memories
she's she accessed recordings of them
that were kind of you could kind
of interact with kind of like in the way
I described it to Jenny kind of like if
you saw Superman one and two where
Superman could interact with his
father who had stored all his memories
and stuff in these crystals he could
talk to Jerel but he wasn't there Jerell
was not there though yeah it was just
that's what I think a ghost you're
probably interacting just with the
fragment of something that was left
behind and the whole thing isn't there
yeah and I think William roll said that
exact thing that he said that fragments
of people might fragment of a person you
can interact with them limited basis
imprint themselves into the environment
yeah that's that's and and a person with
certain psychic abilities can
access fragments of that person that
were there in the past or maybe they
weren't even really in that area somehow
they're accessing people that were
entangled with that area in other words
Friends of Friends of the family which
is that's who she's interacting with
Friends of the
family yeah or people who used to live
in that area right which that would also
be part of the entanglement like quantum
entanglement so she somehow
accessing parts of the past they're like
holographic but she's probably only seen
them in her
mind probably looks real but if you were
to photograph it there'd be nothing
there it's like a
a kind of like a a psychic hologram
imprinted into your
Consciousness it looks like it's there
but it's
not like a message and you can interact
with it same way you know up up to a
certain point because you notice
whenever they talk
about cases like this the interaction
action is never really very long yeah
few few seconds and then there isn't
it's always kind of like things out of
order there isn't any continuity to
it um because that's all that's there
it's like pieces of scrap paper thrown
around and you're reading them you might
read them out of order you don't know
which one came first that that's what it
is I
believe yeah and like I said I'm pretty
sure William R said that what but he
said that later on because he came he
came to visit the family like early on
when it was mostly just Heidi seeing
things and I think after the dad got
scratched too and they started like
thinking about it maybe then they're
like okay we're going to call him but
William roll at this point um he was
thinking he went around and he did all
the you know the scientific like
evaluation and everything like that he
thought um and at least his instruments
indicated to him that that there was um
an unusually high um like number of
positive ions in the house um and I
think they did like a Geological Survey
and they said that there was some kind
of like they were on a fault line or
something like that to me it all sounded
like pseudo sdes maybe and it's just
kind of like well he was saying that
maybe um the you know the high number of
pos positive ions which was unusual that
maybe that is causing hallucinations
like in the little girl because at this
point she was the only one that had seen
anything um so they're like well maybe
that's what is maybe it's like altering
your perception so he was not saying and
I mean he did come out and tell them
he's like these are not ghosts they're
not real but it could be like some
factors in the environment that are
making you see these things you know
what I mean now he did come back later
on and kind of reassess but that's what
he said at
first so um the thing about it like
after he
left uh the weird thing is they decided
to look back I don't remember did they
come across this accidentally or on
purpose they found out that um the
person that had owned the land before or
he hadn't owned the land he was like the
caretaker of the land that the house was
on was actually named like James Gordy
yeah and they thought that was pretty
weird and they said then when they took
Heidi to the cemetery where he was
buried cuz he died in like
1974 they said she went right to his
grave yeah she knew where he was she
knew where it was yeah and she couldn't
even read yeah and they said she was
like three or four and she just went
right up to it and said yeah that's
where he's at yeah and they also they
found if that happened that's quite
compelling yeah and that's what I'm
saying so I so I don't really know if it
happened like that but that's what they
said and they said they also found a
picture of him like in his obituary from
when he died and they mixed it in with a
whole bunch of other photos and like
just laid them out on the table and
showed her and she said oh that's Mr
Gordy like she knew who it was he look
like yeah um you know so they thought
that was like uh pretty
interesting and the thing about it too
is that the dude that had showed up at
the door like with the bloody shirt that
she called KH um apparently there was a
another dude that you know worked on the
property whose name was Lon and I think
they found out later that he'd had his
hand cut off when he was a little boy
like when he was a little like in an
accident or something and um so that
might have been like what she was
perceiving even though I think she that
he was a grownup when she saw him like
with a bandage on his hand but I think
like um somebody that lived around there
like a neighbor said oh yeah like it was
my brother-in-law or some [__] like that
it's like yeah he had his hand cut off
like in a thresher or something like
that some kind of Machinery some kind of
Machinery like accident when he was
younger and um so that and his name was
Lon so that might have been because I
think she identified him too
in the photo because she's like oh
that's Khan like the guy that came to
the door or something and that was who
that was so which like I said if that's
true that's pretty creepy that's pretty
creepy so at this point um they called
Dr R back and in light of this new
information he's starting to think well
okay well maybe Heidi is a a natural
medium and she's picking up this stuff
from the environment so again he's not
saying these are the ghosts are real or
anything like that but she's just
picking up fragments of their
personalities from the environment and
interacting with them it seems like
which means she's accessing accurate
information yeah about people that once
we're in the area by some unknown means
by psychic means but that's that's
fascinating kind of like
psychometry when you touch somebody's
watch or something you know where it's
been right she's doing kind of something
kind of like that yeah and maybe she can
interact according to her they talk to
her yeah cuz she apparently like played
with Mr Gordy like all the time and like
talked to him about all kind of stuff
yeah so I don't know how much of that
was in her mind or like I said she was
accessing fragments of his personality
and interacting with that and kind of
constructing conversations yeah from
that I'm not real sure like I said she
was a little girl so it's kind of hard
to he was asking her if she like to ice
cream and stuff like that wasn't do you
want to go go playing on the swings and
like that's all yeah she's like four you
know what I mean it's like you can't
really have like big like intellectual
discourse with a four-year-old I'm just
you know what I mean right so it's just
kind of that sort of thing it just
sounds like he was sounds like it was uh
an interaction just to keep her occupied
like a
babysitter yeah it does kind of sound
because maybe she was lonely and so she
kind of like accessed without any
without consciously knowing she was
doing it yeah she was accessing somebody
to play with to play with because there
was nobody else around and that's who
was around you know what I mean yeah so
she's using her psychic abilities to
pick up recorded memories and she's kind
of like bringing them back to life in
her mind yeah and she can interact with
them she can see them just like Superman
in the in the D Fortress of Solitude
talking to his dad he's not there but
recorded memories though and Heidi was
actually on the show like being
interviewed and like I said she was a
teenager in her 20s or something like
that and she said that she saw ghosts
just like she saw regular people they
just look like regular people like they
just look normal yeah so so
whatever whatever it is it's strong
enough to uh the effect is strong enough
to convince you that it's there yeah
doesn't look like a a ghostly Apparition
or
anything which is interesting it's an
altern it's a it's a it's a u some kind
of a different state of consciousness
yeah you know how like when you're
uh what do they call it
sleep paralysis where you can open your
eyes you see the room around you but you
also see dream material like a person
standing there they're not really there
right must be something kind of like
that must be it must be like that to
experience it kind of like sleep
paralysis yeah except being like white
walk around
right which like I said I've only had
that happen one time you're interacting
with an illusion but it's accurate the
information it's an accurate
representation of that person that used
to exist weird that just pretty weird
yeah so as I said the documentary kind
of covered a while so they said as Heidi
got older um she didn't see Mr Gordy as
much anymore um and it was almost kind
of like you know after a few years like
she didn't she said she didn't see him
anymore but they said that like the
other Paranormal Activity kind of got
worse and it kind of got more Sinister
um the dark figure that she saw like the
hooded figure that kind of showed up a
lot more and other family members
started to see it um also several of the
family members said that they saw the
ghost of a little girl like running
around in the house so that was
something and I think that even people
that visited them um like saw
apparitions or like heard weird noises
and [__] like that now at this point I
think they were not real satisfied with
Dr
rolls um investigation and like the
explanation that he gave them so at this
point they decided they were going to
call some psychics so like Paranormal
you know investigators kind of so they
got two different ones and they talked
to one who um what's her name Amy Allen
yeah she was on The Dead
Files uh that show on Discovery or TLC
or whatever the hell it's on um she so
she was on here and she was on this case
too and basically she came in and said
that um that there were a bunch of
spirits in the house um some of them
were fine like were benevolent and some
of them were um were evil
obviously um another psychic that came
in said pretty much the same
thing but um
it's the I feel like the second psychic
was more on board with The Wyrick
themselves who like I said were very
religious and they showed them at their
actual church and
everything um which yeah which seemed a
little you
know fire and brimstone it was just kind
of that kind of thing a little bit like
laying on a hands and all that and um
they started to think that maybe the
evil things were demonic where it seems
like the first psychic Amy Allen didn't
think that she just thought well some of
the the bad spirits were just like
[__] in life and now they're
[__] after death death to whereas
like the second psychic seemed to be
like more on the religious bent where
they were like yeah there are probably
like demonic these aren't humans they're
probably like demonic forces or
whatever so because I think the second
psychic also went to the same church as
them they did actually in the
documentary they did kind of go to the
church with them and stuff which was a
little was a little weird to see but
yeah all that kind of stuff I didn't
grow up like that so it's a little weird
to me um but yeah so so they had the
pastor there who they talked to him a
little bit on the documentary as well
and they you know prayed for the family
and all all that and but the thing about
it is that
um it seems like this haunting or
whatever it was was never really
resolved because they lived in this
house for a while like I said they moved
in an 88 when Heidi was four and then I
think they lived there for
for I think until she was a teenager and
then maybe a few years after that I'm
not real enti but they lived there for
quite a while and apparently she kept
seeing stuff the whole time and other
family members saw stuff too and they
didn't really know what to do about it
they didn't really seem
to I don't know they didn't really say
that they were going to try and get an
exorcism or anything like that but they
were almost just kind of like well we're
just going to use our faith or whatever
and just like deal with it because there
doesn't really seem to be anything they
can do about it so they just thought
they would maybe live with
it so they lived there for a while and
then moved out what apparently happened
after
that um Heidi as far as I'm aware I
don't know what she's doing nowadays I
think I was man if she was 4 years old
in 1988 she'd probably be almost 40 now
right if I'm not mathing
incorrectly um but as as far as I know
for a long time afterward like she still
um sees ghosts like all the time they
said in the documentary that it's like
if you have that ability like it never
goes away or whatever so she um I think
they went into this a little bit on the
documentary too like when she was a
teenager she said like all the people in
town you know they heard about the whole
haunted house thing and it's small town
you know what I mean so every was like
kind of making fun of her so she said
that kind of sucked a lot
that she was famous everybody kind of
picked on her about it but apparently
she just kept seeing stuff for the rest
of her life like I said I don't know
what she's doing nowadays because this
was a while back this came out in 2002
so like I said she's probably almost 40
now and I imagine she's still sees stuff
so so there's that and that's kind of
where they left it because there really
wasn't a lot of resolution to this one
they didn't they moved out of the house
eventually um but I guess she still sees
stuff yeah because that's kind of the
ability she had and they never did find
out what the deal was with the ghosts or
were they demons or whatever the hell
you know what I mean yeah I believe her
I mean yeah I mean she's not she didn't
seem like she was making stuff up you
know what I mean too many witnesses too
many witnesses in the family yeah as
long as the story is true they didn't
make it up you know what I mean I would
think that that that uh it's true I mean
I had weirder [__] that happened to me
and what happened
her Danny says the real family even
makes an appearance in the Hollywood
version as well which is cool to see
yeah they showed their photos at the end
but see I kind of wondered about that
because I I watched that cuz they had
the a photo of all of them at the end
like right before they rolled the
credits and they show you know they put
all their names on there but then I was
just kind of like I wonder how they felt
about like when they watched this movie
because the movie doesn't have hardly
anything to do with the case at all you
know what I mean uh Ian England said
love that necklace Jenny thank you very
much yeah I like this too I've had this
for a little while but yeah so so let's
talk about the movie hold on one thing
one second
now one of the reasons why I Believers
because you know even my whole life I
had weird [__] happened to me even
before Mammoth happened I would dream
true a lot I dream as a kid i' dream
things they'd come
true and I think a lot of people when
they're young have that but I don't
remember exactly what it is that I
dreamt true so maybe my memory is
slightly faulty you know what I mean
maybe I just dreed real random common
[__] and it would come true but I
remember it being personal things what
was going to happen to me or what
something that somebody would say to
me but it's been so long I don't
remember the exact details of the dream
but one that I one thing that I do
remember that happened to me I was in
the third
grade I think I was in the third grade
at the time I was watching television
both my parents were at
work and the telephone rang so loudly
that I [__] nearly jumped out of my
skin and went running and I went running
to the telephone and it only rang once I
almost didn't pick it up it's like maybe
they they hung up but I picked it up and
listened and I could hear two people
talking to each other on on the phone
and I was like hello hello they couldn't
hear me and I realized who it was I was
listen Listen to listen to my aunt talk
to somebody else and they had a whole
conversation and it lasted I don't know
30 seconds maybe maybe maybe a minute
and I was going hello hello and I was
trying to get their attention but they
wouldn't they they couldn't hear
me and I said you know this my aunt
Lana which I had only seen Aunt Lana a
couple times really and she didn't live
anywhere near me well the voices just
faded away
and I was like wow that's weird maybe it
wasn't them it was just some I figured I
was a kid I was like maybe there's just
something wrong with the telephone and I
hung it up went back watched television
10 minutes later a car pulls in the
driveway it was my aunt Lana and she was
with her new husband she'd married I'd
never seen the guy they asked where my
mom was and I said and I said oh they're
they're at work said come on with us
we'll get something to eat so I jumped
in the back seat and they're driving and
all of a sudden I realized that they're
having the same conversation I heard on
the
telephone and I said I just heard you
guys talking about this on the telephone
and they looked at me like I was [__]
crazy I said yeah yeah I heard you I
picked up the telephone and I heard you
guys talk about this they're yeah yeah
okay they blew me off because I was just
a kid yeah and it's just that's a weird
thing to say so was like whatever kid
yeah I heard you guys talk about this on
the
telephone so it was a premonition yeah
even though it wasn't anything important
no which is probably
I got somehow got a psychic warning that
my aunt Lana was on her way over and you
were going to hear what they were going
to say and and I heard what they were
going to say in the future and they were
talking about my mom and it was
verbatim that's pretty weird yeah yeah
you've told me that story before yeah
but like I said I just thought it was
funny that it's like you get a
premonition but it's about something
that's like not yeah really all that
important could be that could be that
this girl was having something kind of
like that but they were premonitions of
things that happened to the past in the
post cognition yeah like post cognition
she's accessing
it Danny Rowling said the Hollywood
version makes the mother look crazy it
does um and I will say that it also
makes the mom's sister the aunt look
kind of like um a not a bum but somebody
who doesn't have their life together and
it's just kind of like hey I'm moving in
with you guys all right because I kind
of feel like they didn't go super into
this on the documentary because they did
talk to the sister and all that who
looked like she had her life together
you know what I mean when um Lisa and
Andy bought the house in Georgia in real
life apparently the sister they asked
it's like oh why don't you come and
there's like property next to us or a
house that's empty next to us for sale
like why don't you move out here and
then you know what I mean because she
could look after the kid and all this
other kind of stuff and they wanted to
be close to family and everything so I
think that's how it was in the movie
they made it look like the sister had
just broken up with you know one of a
long succession of dudes so there was
that and she's like yeah I'm just broke
and she just like moves into this like
pretty much invites herself like she
shows up at the house with her [__] all
in the trunk and like the the husband
already knows he's like opens the trunk
and it's like mhm I know yeah like he
already knew and she moves into like
this old beat up trailer like a mobile
home on the property
um like I said that's not really what
happened I think the sister actually
bought a house or bought property next
to theirs so she could help out with the
kid and everything like that so I think
they kind of did the sister a little bit
dirty also and in the movie they made
the mom they they leaned very hard on
the
generational um psychic
angle because they even started the
movie with the mom Lisa everyone's names
were the same the real people in the
movie they didn't change the names like
they did in Haunting in Connecticut but
yeah everyone had the same names um but
they implied that Lisa and her sister
what was her sister's name uh [__] now I
can't remember I have it written down
but now I can't remember what it was
Sylvia I'll remember in a second but um
whatever the sister's name was so that
both of them also had psychic powers and
their mom had had psychic powers like
they had visions and stuff and like saw
dead people but they kind of had it so
that Lisa the mom she hated it and so
she was basically like medicating
herself to make it stop whereas the
sister was kind of more freewheeling
about it it's like man you just got to
like chill and like let it happen and
she's kind of the one that's telling the
kid Heidi oh it's okay you know we both
have it too we were born with the veil
and actually there was a book written
about wrick you know the real one which
was called The Veil so maybe they went
more into that in the book and maybe
that's where they got the idea from the
Hollywood movie they didn't get they
didn't talk about that in the um in the
documentary though is or at least they
didn't talk about it that much you know
what I mean cuz did the mom Lisa did she
say that she saw anything or the sister
saw anything like yeah they saw some
[__] later but I don't think they said
oh we grew up seeing dead people no but
they leaned real hard on that like in
the Hollywood version like Haunting in
Connecticut 2 ofor yeah that it was
genetic which maybe it is I've heard
that before but they leaned real hard
into that so they actually did kind of
make the mom look like a little bit of a
lunatic because she was just kind of
like oh I've always been able to see
dead people but I don't want to see dead
people so I'm taking all this medication
to like make it stop you know what I
mean so she seemed like she was flipping
out a little having the veil they mostly
talking about that placental thing huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can explain that
to him if yeah it's just well that's a
it's a very old
wies tale like an old myth about a baby
that's born with kind of like it's it's
like a little bit of like a skin kind of
thing like this glimmery kind of skin
goes over thing like over their face
over their face yeah and um I've also
heard it called a call I've heard it
called that too um if there there's an
old wives tale that if a baby is born
with that over their face that means
they have Second Sight that they're a
psychic um so that's kind of what they
were getting into with this they were
kind of talking about that folklore
which I thought was kind of interesting
because I always thought that was an
interesting bit of folklore but um but
yeah they leaned real hard on that so I
guess what they were trying to do in the
movie was they were trying to introduce
conflict because when Heidi starts
seeing what appears to be dead people
when she sees Mr Gordy and then they
find out later on that Mr Gordy was a
real person and all this other kind of
stuff that there's going to be conflict
because the mom doesn't want it to be
true because she's wanted to raise her
like not like that you know what I mean
cuz she doesn't like it so she doesn't
want her daughter to have to go through
the same thing so I guess I see what
where they were going with it now really
okay so the beginning of the movie other
than all the stuff with the mom actually
seeing visions of of her mom um and
other and other things like seeing
premonitions kind of the first part of
the movie maybe the first 20ish minutes
kind of what is she doing back there
playing with the carpet oh okay kind of
goes along you know Mr Gordy shows up
they make him look more more Sinister I
guess um and for a while cuz I have seen
this movie before but I kind of forgot
where they went with it so for a while I
think you were in the bathroom during
this PO point but for a while they're
almost making it seem like Mr Gordy was
like a bad guy like the villain like he
doesn't end up being spoiler alert but
um they did kind of like set it up like
that a little bit at the
beginning so they kind of make him sort
of scary and all this other kind of [__]
but then they get into all these other
ghosts that people are seeing and then
there's other things going on like Andy
the dad um like their dog gets caught in
this trap in the woods and they find a
bunch of other ones and they're like oh
well whoever lived on this land before
must have been you know a Trapper
whatever and then they say yeah there
was this guy that used to live here who
was a
taxidermist and he was also part of the
Underground Railroad so he would hide
escaped slaves and like help them
you know along their way or whatever and
he had like all these hiding places
where he would put them and all this
other kind of [__] so apparently like a
lot of the ancestors of those escaped
slaves like now kind of come here like
for pilgrimage or whatever which all of
that that I just said that doesn't have
anything to do with the original story
none of the stuff about the Underground
Railroad none of the stuff about the you
know the underground um you know the the
pit down there or anything like that or
the guy that was ATT tax theer that
doesn't have anything to do with like
anything that happened at the real story
so it's like they just added all of that
well like I said it was kind of like The
Haunting in Connecticut where they added
the whole thing about um you know the
the guy trying with the psychic and with
the bodies with all the spells on them
like all the black magic so so that's
kind of the thing they're they're taking
a story like the bones of the story and
adding all of this frippery to
it so Mr Gordy was the guy in the movie
who owned the property
prior and like I said they're trying to
almost make you believe that he was a
bad guy because the pastor comes to the
house and says oh well I hope you guys
are friendlier than the last guy that
owned this place James Gordy man what an
[__] that dude was or anything like
that because he didn't want people on
his property because they said because
this was on the Underground Railroad
like you have people coming through like
wanting to see it you know what I mean
cuz it's kind of like historical so
they're kind of trying to set it up like
Mr Gordy is a bad guy and like the
little girl is in danger and all this
other kind of [__] but it turns out
spoiler alert like I said this movie's
10 years old so don't don't come at me
but it turns out that the dude who was
he was Mr Gordy's ancestor what the [__]
was his name I can't even remember now
the taxidermist guy yeah he was helping
some escaped slaves get out but then
some of them he's like oh I kind of like
this one so I'm going to keep it and
then he was Taxidermy them so he was
like a serial killer essentially is what
he was doing and so I guess it's weird
because I was reading a synopsis of the
plot and the synopsis said that because
the story went in the movie that the
taxidermist like all the towns folk who
were implying who they were implying
were in the clan um found out that he
was helping slaves so they dragged him
out his house they cut him open and
stuffed him like you would a Taxidermy
animal and killed him you know what I
mean and everybody's like oh my God
that's so horrible cuz he was such a
nice man but then it turns out that he
was the bad guy the weird thing about it
though is that the plot synopsis I read
said yeah all these like clan people
came and killed him and stuff like that
I said but the implication was that the
escaped slaves or friends of theirs or
something like that found out that he
was a serial killer and they were the
ones that killed him it wasn't the clan
like cuz they just showed them putting
hoods on like not white hoods not like
Clan PS just like regular bag hoods you
know that's kind of how they started
though yeah yeah yeah but I'm just
saying that I think they were trying to
set it up as though that was because
that was what the the story was but then
you find out later that that guy was
actually a serial killer and nobody knew
yeah so they were the ones that found
out like cuz they found this big pit and
it's like where he'd been keeping the
slaves that he kept and like he starved
them down there and then he would like
turn them into Taxidermy because they
end up finding like the tax there were
actually three Clans in different eras
this is kind of a ahistorical cuz the
clan really the clan as you would know
it uh only started after slavery it was
over already so they didn't have
anything to do with that you know what
I'm talking about yeah that was that was
Reconstruction Era yeah that's when they
and they were they really if you if you
looked at what they were at yeah they
they tried to get get in the way of
[__] voting rights that's one of the
things the race war kicked off here
[__] almost instantly but their main
thing was trying to fighting Catholics a
lot of people don't know that they were
yeah they did not like the [__]
federal government
and uh they were paranoid about
Catholics they didn't really care that
much about black people until that was
that was later and then you know like
the third Clan that's what you have now
but there there's not many of them
basically neo-nazis is what they're
they're kind of like yeah they're just
not around anymore either the second
clan that was the invisible Empire they
were big in the 50s 40s and 50s they
were [__]
huge but they're gone now they were
nowhere near nowhere near the side
it's cuz the the guy that their leader
got arrested for damn raping a woman on
a train that was the end of that they
all left cuz they were Christian they
had they had people forget that those
were Christian groups yeah so you know
[__] but the invisible Empire [__]
vanished because the leader was a crook
yeah yeah um let's see Zach says Jenny
have you ever written a story about
premonitions always thought they were a
really cool storytelling device I don't
think I have although I will say that
one of my very favorite movies about a
premonition um is the psychic which is a
Lucho fuli movie kind of like a Galo but
it has like Supernatural elements and I
feel like it's one of his underrated
ones it's also called seven notes in
black but the whole thing is like the
woman is a psychic and she has a
premonition at the beginning which is
kind of disjointed and you
think that it's going to go one way but
it's really satisfying because you watch
the movie and then all of the stuff that
she saw in her vision is like
recontextualize it's really clever I
like dardon Sati wrote the um wrote the
screenplay he also wrote house by the
cemetery in a lot of um his other Gore
films but so if you haven't seen Lucho
fuli's the psychic if you're into movies
about premonitions I that's a one that I
really really like a lot I just I just
find that really satisfying that the
resolution of that DVD dragon asking me
if I experienced anything paranormal in
the Army and say yeah a near-death
experience and an out of- Body
Experience yeah I talked about it did a
show on uh there another episode we did
I it's called out of- body experiences
yeah I think that's what it was called
yeah and I tell the whole story in there
yeah um Zach says how good were the
Accents in the Show versus the
movie um they tone down they still had
kind of Southern Accents in the movie
but like way toned down from the actual
people probably you know what I mean
they wanted to like give the impression
that people the people were from Georgia
but they still wanted people to like
understand what they were saying I guess
so they like the accents weren't as
thick but yeah so I will say much like
here's the problem that I had with both
of the Hollywood versions of these while
I don't begrudge them adding a backstory
cuz it's a fictional story it's like you
can't just have and then there were all
these random ghosts wandering around and
it didn't mean anything it's a fictional
story it has to have a structure so I
get if you want to like add a backstory
Haunting in Connecticut they did the
whole thing with the black magic Seance
thing and like the guy wanting to use
the dead bodies to amp up the psychic's
powers or whatever the [__] it was and
like with all the dead bodies in the
house and in this one they added the
backstory of this serial killer who was
actually killing Escape slaves while
ostensibly helping them escape on the
Underground Railroad which is kind of a
cool idea for a backstory but again I
feel like it's a little convoluted
there was just too much I don't know
there was too much going on you know
what I'm saying it's just too much going
on I think they should have like
simplified the backstory a little bit
and I will say that the Hollywood
version of the movie I feel like the
whole middle section of the movie was
basically just that damn girl that
little kid running off into the woods
like I was like would somebody please
watch her she just keeps like running
off she gets up in the middle of the
night she sees a ghost standing out in
the yard and she like runs out there
into the woods and stuff like that and
then like so I feel like the whole
middle part of and I know this is an
exaggeration but I feel like the whole
middle part of the movie was just her
parents running around in the woods in
the dark being like Heidi Heidi like
they kept losing her you know what I
mean so it's just kind of like that's
what I meant when I said it felt like
the middle of the movie it was just kind
of like spinning its Wheels
because it it just felt like a lot of it
was her
seeing stuff running off and then like
her parents like frantically like
looking for her because they can't keep
an eye on her for 5 seconds you know
what I mean so there's that like I said
I liked the
idea of the whole Underground Railroad
thing I think that would have been a
cool thing but I think they just I just
think they over complicated it too much
and they did that with the first movie
too I feel like they should have
streamlined the
backstory well and the thing about it is
that
this story in particular and even The
Haunting and Connecticut story probably
more than this one cuz this one The
Haunting and Georgia the real quote
unquote
story um it doesn't really have a
narrative either um you know because
it's like yeah she saw Mr Gordy he hung
out he was fine for a while and then she
didn't see him anymore but then she saw
like some scarier ones and the end that
was like pretty much it they didn't know
you know who those ones were or anything
like that but in in Connecticut I felt
like had a little bit more of a story to
it because at least there was the whole
human drama about like you know the kid
and he was dying of cancer and all that
other kind of stuff and him kind of
getting taken over and that so I kind of
feel like they had less excuse with the
first one to kind of go wildly Off
Script and like do their own [__] with
it I didn't mind what they did but I
just thought it was too much it was too
over complicated this one doesn't have
as
much I don't like not as much substance
to it in the sense of like a narrative
story because it's just like a bunch of
random ghosts and it's like yeah it was
this guy that used to live here and [__]
like that so I can see why they had to
add more story to it but I just don't
know I don't know I I just feel like it
was too much and then they kind of
concentrated a lot too on the mom like
learning
to you know there there's kind of this
repeating thing through there where she
was supposed to like let them in because
all these ghosts were like asking for
help like for their bodies to be found
and all this other stuff and she didn't
want to deal with it cuz she didn't like
her psychic powers so at the end she has
to actually like let them all in like to
release them or whatever so they almost
kind of made it more the mom's story
than the daughter's story if that makes
any sense you know what I mean so which
like I said fine but I don't know I
didn't love it I didn't love it I I just
found my attention wandering a lot
during the second one yeah I didn't
think it was very good I didn't think I
didn't think it was a compelling story
it was too complicated yeah started it
started to Veer too far away from the
case they should have kept what it was
and like I said if they needed to add it
a narrative structure which you do cuz
it's a movie but you could have come up
with something simpler than what they
came up with because they were trying to
incorporate Mr Gordy who was from the
real case and they were trying to
incorporate it him in a way that was
like oh well let's make him seem like
the villain at first but then it turns
out that he was a good guy all along
just like he was in real life but then
we have to add all this other story and
it's like a Twist and it's like you know
this guy we also thought was a good guy
he was really a bad guy and so they were
trying to like do a Switcheroo which is
fine but I feel like they like I said I
think they over complicated it um also
the editing in this um was
real uh kinetic let's put it that way so
there was a lot of and I feel like this
was there's a lot of horror movies it's
it's getting better now thankfully but I
feel like in the 2000s and in the early
2010s a lot of horror movies especially
kind of big budget ones like this were
let's just like flash all this imagery
after it like you know what I mean and
it's just like I'm please stop that you
know what I mean it's just like that's
it's not scary it's just like annoying
after a while so I kind of feel like
that was an issue also like it kind of
had that like real hyperactive editing
style like during parts of it which I
don't really like with that and I think
that's kind of what why I didn't like a
lot of big budget Hollywood movies from
the 2000s you know what I mean like the
2000s and the 2010s and still until they
started chilling out and like not doing
that so much later on but I mean this
came out in 2013 but it still has that
early
2000s that 2000s editing which kind of
drives me crazy you know I I like I said
the 90s and I've talked about how much I
really don't like a lot of horror movies
from the 90s maybe the 2000s are worse
um um especially because a lot of it was
just remakes you know what I mean just
kind of big budget soulless remakes of
yeah trying to be a sensational as
possible Classics yeah and it's not
effective they're not scary at all
they're really not like I said it had
like a lot of hyper kinetic um editing
it's just kind of like well we're going
to take this you know classic story that
had just like regular looking people
everyone's going to look like a model
you know it's just going to be it's it's
just very slick and I didn't like I
don't really like slick horror movies it
just it doesn't work for me yeah and so
I kind of feel like a lot of the 2000s
horror movies were like that and this
one was not as bad as that but it did
have a little bit of that
lingering uh that lingering stench to it
I'm going to say you know what I mean
but uh but that's that um yeah Danny
rling said the sackhead conductor AKA
scarecrow conductor yeah I mean I do
like people with sacks over their head
it is kind of
scary um yeah JN gor said the clan was
infiltrated by feds in the 1950s and 60s
to absolutely turn public opinion
against them they reviewed it just
yesterday yeah man it'd be great to do a
show on them but somebody just asked
like to doing a show on the clan would
be a huge [__] show but it is a [__]
the comment section would be a [__] show
but it it that they were it might be
interesting it be interesting because an
interesting topic um you'd really have
to dig into [__] because you can't
really trust any information
that you hear about it what ended up
happening is the clan was very
um uh convenient all right very
convenient for southerners they could
blame everything bad about the south on
the clan well they did it
nah okay Hollywood will portray it as
the clan went around lynching black
people no regular Southerners did that
the clan would show up after it
sometimes just to take pictures yeah we
did this they didn't do it they just
they talked big [__] okay tried to be as
important as they they tried to be super
important but they weren't that
important they were a two bit outfit
really most of the time I I wrote a lot
you know what it's [__] up I wrote a
lot in my books about a lot of unsolved
murders of um you know a lot of uh black
activists and stuff like that like
around that time period some of it was
Clan but um a lot of it was cops cops
yeah it was cops yeah so some of those
cops were in the clan too but I'm just
saying lot of it was you didn't have to
be in the clan to do to do that matter
of fact a lot of the people that were
doing what she's talking about like I
said my family from [__] Mississippi
back when Mississippi burned all right
my dad knew all about it his father
actually testified against some of these
guys cuz he overheard him talking about
it when when they were playing pinball
machines and he was a little kid had to
do with the they firebomb something
things and some little girls got burned
up that was another thing that turned
Clan was not the clan was not behind
that it was just teenage boys white
teenage boys they were they were SE Pro
segregationists but they did not want
any kind of racial
integration um they were just kind of
losers really but the South was kind of
a lawless
area you had cops right but the cops a
lot of times were the offenders they
were yeah yeah the cops were like the
warrior class so you'd have federal
agents coming in here and and you'd have
I Outsiders and they would consider it
like their stirring up trouble down here
well they just kill them they knew where
they were cuz they knew what motel they
were at yep theyd come out of that motel
and they pull them over with a police
car and walk them out [__] kill him
and then just shoot them yeah yeah and
then they get their Bud jump in the car
and drive their car somewhere and then
ditch the car somewhere else they never
found the bodies I mean amazingly I mean
the bodies they did find um yeah a lot
of times an alarming amount of the
suspects who they never caught obviously
but a lot of the suspect were yeah in
general the the clan was [__] talkers
they just [__] talkers mostly they
weren't doing most of it it was what you
would call regular southern people were
doing it but you see it's very
convenient nowadays for southerners to
go oh it wasn't us that was the clan nah
Hollywood blew them up into Hollywood
blew them up into the bad guys because
[__] they got suits so they must have
did it they got they they they got that
white suit like I said they did they did
do bad [__] but it wasn't always done
sometimes it was just regular ass people
when they did when the clan did bad [__]
they were doing the same kind of thing
an average Souther would an average bad
Southerner would have
done you know right that's what I'm
saying so but most of the [__] was just
Southerners yeah or cops like I said lot
well yeah those were the the cops yeah
um and judges yeah that too and just
guys that worked and I think that goes
long way toward saying like why a lot of
those crimes from that time are unsolved
so because I think were Black Ops um the
South did not want to be in the union it
just didn't so that was why they were
just trying to get the feds out of
here the clam was interesting though
they were kind of like nowadays you'd
call them conspiracy theorists they're
paranoid about coming off the damn gold
standard they didn't believe in the
Federal Reserve Bank they thought that
that you could Jimmy that they thought
that Catholics would take over the
United States and make it a make it a
theocracy it had all kinds of worries
you know it was they would pass little
books and pamphlets
around like all the Catholics are taking
over Danny says uh the money finding
aspect was kind of cool from the movie
yeah um and I don't think I think that
was a movie only Edition I don't
remember them mentioning that on the
documentary and I don't remember seeing
that in anything about the W reconning
um in the movie if you haven't seen it
um the little girl tells them oh Mr
Gordy said that there's money buried on
the property and the mom is just kind of
like shut up what are you talking about
but the dad's like H maybe there's
something too that so he goes and digs
him and the sister-in-law and they find
like a whole bunch of coins like you
know real expensive coins or whatever
but I don't think that happened in real
life but that was one of the things in
the movie that kind of made them believe
that oh maybe Heidi was telling the
truth about this Mr Gordy person because
it's like hey she knew the money was
there Zach says I also hated the look of
the cinematography in a lot of 200
movies yeah me too um so many scenes
just washed in a single color like teal
or beige yeah I kind of feel like all of
the movies from that era were either
like teal or orange yeah it's like a
filter over the whole thing yeah it just
looked so bad it looked so bad John Gora
said the only remake I liked from that
era was The Hills Have Eyes that was
actually pretty good um Dawn of the Dead
remake was okay I honestly The Dawn of
the Dead remake which I think came out
in 2004 I think that was the best one
yeah of all of the ones that came out I
mean that was pretty [__] good I saw
that in the theater um he went a
slightly different Direction with it but
I thought they did a really good job I
also I didn't mind the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre remake it wasn't great but it
wasn't as bad as I was expecting so
that's about charitable as but the other
[__] like the Friday the 13th remake
like all the remakes they did they were
just lame they were just kind of lame
like I said everybody looked like a
model it was just kind of like
everything was like super slick the
thing that I like about the original
movies was like how grungy they were you
know what I mean how realistic they
seemed so if you're just going to make
it look like a [__] music video
what's the point of that that's not that
kind of movie you know what I mean
especially if it's like a slasher or
something like that I just think that's
so very silly um but let me see hold on
uh talking about House of
Wax yeah so Danny rolling said so why
did the clan kill the conductor again in
this film because he was helping slaves
or because he was turning them into taxy
figures see that's the thing and I think
that this was they okay and admittedly I
don't think they did a great job of
getting this across in the movie and
please correct me if I'm wrong I've seen
this movie two times that's
it but I think at first they implied I
don't even think they implied it was the
clan they kind of implied it was the
clan but they because they showed people
putting some hoods on but it wasn't Clan
hoods it was just like regular ass like
burlap saacks or whatever so they just
showed all of these people coming out
and dragging out the conductor and
stuffing him you know what I mean like
cutting him open and putting all like
the tax Army [__] in there and like
killing him and so everybody nowadays
thinks it's like oh my God all of these
[__] racist ass people like they knew
that he was helping all the Escape
slaves so they killed him you know what
a bunch of
[__] but I think the implication the
real story and I think they only touched
on this very briefly was that the either
some of the escaped slaves or their
friends or family members something like
that found out that he was killing some
of the people that he was supposedly
helping and they were the ones that
killed him because I thought there was a
scene with some of the other like
escaped slaves that had gotten away
coming back and putting the hoods on and
they killed him because they found out
what he had did so it wasn't they
weren't killing him because he was
helping slaves they were killing him
because he was a serial killer and they
found out what he did I thought that was
and like I said I don't think they got
that across very well because I wasn't
sure and then I read this other plot
synopsis where they said oh the clan
like killed him because he was helping
slaves I'm like yeah but that's what
you're supposed to think at the
beginning but then like I thought later
on there was kind of like a flash where
they showed that it was actually the
escaped slaves themselves that came back
and were like hey we know what you did
[__] and we're going to like
kill you for it and like but they put
hoods on you know what I mean yeah I
thought that that's what they showed you
know what I'm saying uh Hugo said I
liked the blob remake 1988 yeah and I
mean because we were talking about
remakes from the 2000s which a lot of
those sucked but I will argue that the
1988 remake of The Blob one of the best
horror remakes of all time that is a
great great movie and honestly I like
the original blob too but it's campy you
know it's silly all of the teenagers are
40 years old um which a lot of them were
in the 50s it's just they looked like
that old but the 88 one was like was
great I really liked it the special
effects were really good we reviewed it
not too long ago didn't we but yeah I I
will and and I kind of feel like a lot
of people maybe don't uh talk about it
but I think that's one of the best
horror remakes
ever maybe other than the thing although
I did a video today if you guys don't
subscribe to my scare Salon Channel you
should go over there and do it right now
I just put up a video today my top five
favorite movies from 1982 because I'm
doing my top five favorite movies from
every year since I was born and I'm on
1982 because this is the 10th video that
I've done and one of the ones was the
thing and in there I kind of got into an
existential crisis about cuz I kind of
feel like a lot of people see the thing
as a remake of the thing from another
world from
1951 I would argue it's not exactly a
remake is it what I mean the thing the
thing no no it's an individual they're
both based on the same book b the thing
is CLO Carpenters thing is kind of
closer closer to the book The 1951 one
is good too we reviewed it not too long
ago but they had to change a lot um
because of the time period and because
they didn't have the money I guess to do
it the way it was in the book so I kind
of feel like so in the in the 1951
version it's just like a guy like the
monster is just like a guy I saw or I
read a Illustrated novel a long time ago
when I was a
kid
based on the book who goes there I think
isn't it isn't it called who goes there
yeah it came out in
1938 it's in in general it's like it's
like Carpenter is the thing but I
remember it being very political
too um when the thing when the thing
took over a person not only did it not
only did that the alien didn't so much
copy that person's Behavior it adopted
that person's
Behavior
so if I remember correctly SP I was a
little kid when I when I read it the the
thing ends up being a hardcore
capitalist oh no I'm going to have to go
read it like I read it when I was when I
was a teenager but I don't remember yeah
I think I remember um and it had to do
with voting and capitalism and all kinds
of stuff so the the so the alien itself
was making kind of like poignant
political comments in in in in the in
the comic that I read which really
neither of the movies did did that yeah
not really it was kind of like a
critique of
America okay you know what I'm talking
about which yeah like they got the best
democracy money could buy that kind of
it was that kind of [__] you well I'm
gon to have to go reread it yeah was
pretty something like that but [__] I
was a little kid though I may be totally
wrong but just yeah it's been a long
time since you read it was asking for
people's proxies that was another thing
it was
doing so the alien was becoming like a
human
oh okay that's interesting yeah but yeah
but I so I kind of got into a thing
where it's like I would kind of argue
that maybe the thing from 1982 is not
exactly a remake because it's different
enough the setup is the same of the 1951
one and the 1982 one but other than that
it's not really I don't know like the
general bones of it are similar but it's
it goes off in such a different
direction that I don't really think it's
a remake um Denny say says were the
bodies found in the M shaft the family
members of the blind old black women
that went missing yeah I thought that
was the implication because it was the
two that fell in love you know what I
mean the she found them like Taxidermy
down there like in the secret whatever
and I I was led to believe unless I'm
remembering it wrong that she came there
um and the grandson said to Andy that he
like yeah um you know they these two
supposedly um you know escaped or they
were here but then like they never got
to where they were and they never knew
what happened to them so I'm I think
that that's that's who that was but yeah
there was a bunch of other bodies down
in there too but yeah Ian said he
watched it for the first
time wow man I can't believe that well I
was kind of getting into that on my
other video too because I'm just kind of
like it's kind of because we grew up in
that era yeah you know it's easy for us
to like oh everybody's seen that you
know what I mean but it's like like yeah
but then there's people that weren't
born when that came out obviously and
it's just like and they might be like
you know little baby horror fans too and
it's like they've seen like all the new
[__] that comes out but it's like now
they have all this old [__] they got to
see and I haven't even caught up on all
the old [__] man there's like still
movies from the 30s and 40s that I want
to see that I haven't seen yet my dad
took me to see that like three times in
a row Sawmill Square Mall in Mississippi
the thing that scared the [__] out of my
dad scared the [__] we he loved it
though I loved it too like man it's a
terrifying thinking about what would
happen if that thing got out
yeah Kurt Russell doing his thing mant
Russell in his prime I would argue and I
mentioned this in my other video that I
put up today too that if the thing the
monster from the thing was a real
organism oh you'd be [__] yeah we
would be so [__] yeah I would think
nothing like that exists or have been I
would hope I would hope as old as the
Earth is it have been here by
now would have been here millions of
years ago yeah and abor the planet it's
funny because we watched yeah now did we
watch was it ciles react or was it
villagers
react to the to the thing yeah so the
cile so it's two guys from where are
they from Pakistan Pakistan two
Pakistani guys um or India maybe it's
India I can't remember Muslim but I
think they're and they show them movies
and so I loved watching them like react
to horror movies that they've never seen
like especially ones from the ' 80s and
they watched the thing it's just it's
interest it's interesting to me because
you can see how something that is way
before their time cuz they're young and
doesn't have they don't have any
cultural context for it they didn't grow
up like watching these movies or
anything like that but it still
resonated with them yeah you know what I
mean they still what's funny is that
they became big Arnold Schwarzenegger
fans yeah they love Arnold Arnold every
time they see an Arnold movie they oh
yeah saw man they were they were super
into Terminator and
Predator it's hilarious yeah so now they
feel like they know Arnold every time
they see him they
go and Sylvester Stallone they love
Sylvester Stallone Rocky and yeah they
love rock yeah but I I thought that was
so funny that they watched the thing and
they were just they got really into it
like it scared the crap out of them yeah
they weren't quite sure how it worked
they yeah they kind of perceived it more
as possession being possessed yeah
rather than the alien like replicating I
don't know if they ever got over that
Miss c yeah cuz they seem to talk about
it as though it was like like a
possession deal rather than like the
alien like actually copying yeah
mimicking you the body yeah I don't know
if they actually got that but it scared
the crap out of them yeah they also
really liked I I thought this was love
[__] they they love [__] crle yeah
they do well he's [__] cool everybody
like everybody the world over I mean
everybody recognizes coolness when they
see his hair man his his beard the other
guy goes his he goes he's a handsome man
what's funny is that he he looks like a
paston though or something he looks
Arabic because got that big full beard
and he's got like so much hair in facial
hair and [__] yeah they liked it they
also really liked the six sense which I
thought was very entertaining and that's
we watched one the other day they
watched cuz I wanted I was curious to
see like how a comedy would translate
they watched The Hangover and they
thought that [__] was hilarious yeah
yeah we plug in that channel what's it
called again uh uh [__] it's called
ciles react ciles there's another one
called villagers react yeah which is
kind of along the same lines ciles is
better it's got better guys but ciles is
better like I like those two guys
they're two they're two younger guys
yeah in their 20s they're real
intelligent guys but they're they don't
have any cultural context but they don't
need it they they they' learned it they
they became Arnold Schwarzenegger fans
and Sylvester Stallone fans kind of like
we did back in the 80s where Sylvester
Stone and Arnold you're kind of well
which one do you like better
because that battle was going on back
then in all young men's Minds which one
was better well they're already they're
getting that now they're just getting
that now right yeah so it's like so it's
funny that it's just like this many
years later it's like they're getting
that so they and they're having the same
arguments that people like when they we
first saw that [__] back in like
hilarious Ian England says maybe we are
things see we wouldn't know would
we um John gor said I like the bit where
the old doctor is figuring out i' to
take the thing like two years to take
the whole earth yeah and I think that's
what's so scary about that movie is that
it really did a lot with that concept
because and John Carpenters seemed to
realize or you know this might have been
the original book too but it's just like
if a organism like this came to Earth it
would take like no time at all for it to
like Wipe Out the human race it would
just take it over you know what I mean
it's part of his lovecraftian Series
yeah and you said what was what's that
guy do the Lovecraft with the original
book it was the creature was kind of
like that
but Lovecraft talked about a creature
that's like that too a shago yeah in in
in the mountains of Madness and the
thing is basically a shago which was an
amiea like alien
creature that was got enslaved as basic
labor they did they weren't intelligent
they they had an animal intelligence but
their bodies could become anything it
needed to build they used them for
construction somehow the shago got a
hold of a brain out of one of the old
ones which are the aliens that ran them
and they be then they passed that
information through each other and they
all became as intelligent as an old one
and they rebelled and killed him and
that's and they did that on Earth too
that's why that's why that's why the
alien city was abandoned when they found
it on Antarctica because all the Shag
offs killed all everybody and then they
froze to death if I remember
correctly some of them were still alive
they were in
hibernation well that's kind of the
Genesis of this story it was Frozen in
hibernation when they found it and it
was an alien there was a spaceship there
instead of a city but it'd be real close
to kind of
like in the mountains of Madness had it
been a city instead of a splin saucer
that they found well it is very it is
very low crafy and but the thing is is I
also think some of the old ones were
alive in in in in the book weren't some
of the old ones alive they looked frozen
but they weren't yeah that's what I
remember they had wings and [__] they
look like a pod with a bunch of
tentacles on the bottom of
them then I think sha I think there were
some shag offs that were still
alive but they could absorb you and copy
you so they were good for construction
yeah it's just a big
amoeba which like I said that's scary as
[__] I think I would argue that the the
thing in the thing is the scariest
monster ever and I don't even know if
you could make one scarier than that you
couldn't beat it that's what I mean you
couldn't defeat it there would just be
no way no way no civilization couldn't
do it n It could only be done by
individuals and there wouldn't be there'
be not enough strong individuals to do
it you'd be outnumbered kind of like the
the the the Body Snatchers it' be the
same way yeah similar well yeah because
and and because there'd really be no way
of knowing yeah who you were dealing
with yeah that's what's so great about
that movie is that nobody knows who's
the thing and who's not yeah see alien
Xenomorphs that be easy oh you just need
guns with those you can easily identify
the damn alien so you can fight him yeah
cuz obviously they look like aliens and
they didn't have technology well the
thing could impersonate a person and use
technology so cuz it knew whatever the
person knew was yeah and uh they would
just take over and if you just were
alone with one you couldn't beat it hos
it couldn't beat it we'd be totally
hosed yeah and they could make alien
technology it made a V flying saucer out
of [__] helicopter CS
yep yep it did like I said we would be
super screwed if that happened in real
life DVD Dragon said the part in The
Blob 1988 where that guy got broken in
half and pulled through the bookcases oh
it's like it broke my brain the guy
getting pulled down the pipes oh man I
remembered that scene for like years and
years afterward he said lots of gnarly
kills in that movie that's what's
[__] great about it it's the gore in
that is so great just so
good um Hugo said the prequel of the
thing 2011 was not bad didn't like the
CGI yeah I kind of wish they'd gone more
practical but I actually quite liked
that we saw it in the theater they went
practical they they they did all that
[__] in Practical effects and then the
company said nah let's go ahead and do
CG over the Practical effects so it
looks like a new movie underneath those
underneath those that CG there's
practical effects under there they said
they were good they ought to release
some damn practical version of it now
but I don't think the they should man
yeah I mean they probably like make some
more money on it yeah because you're
going to have like crotchy old farts
like me that just kind of like and I
said this in my video too because I
would argue that the effects in the
thing which came out like what 40 years
ago yeah um they still look amazing yeah
they're they're good you could tell it's
an effect but sure but you can also tell
that that that that those objects are
there and then people are interacting
with them so because the thing about it
is when you see CGI I can also tell that
that is an effect because it doesn't
look like it's really there and all I
can picture in my mind is the actor
farting around on a blue screen yeah and
them adding it all
later so I'm I'm always going to be a
big advocate of like interacting with
[__] that's actually there think 2011
was a good one though it was I did I
actually did like I've rewatched it many
times it's good yeah we've seen it
several times we saw in the theater and
yeah he bought it and like we've watched
it probably four or five times since
then and I actually really liked it you
know another one that I like you a
predator one really I think is the best
movie ever made of its type at least
Predator 2 is okay but I actually like
Predators I liked that as well yeah
where they're on the alien Reserve
Planet I actually when I first saw it I
go yeah this is pretty good it's pretty
good but then the more I like the more I
watched it the more I liked it that's a
[__] excellent movie it's right there
with the first one alth I'm gonna give
it to the first one you know but it it's
in that same
ballport and I don't give a [__] what
people say I like [__] a VP one and
two they're all right they're they're
entertaining yeah yeah they're fun just
extra
[__] now the that last Predator movie
though the one the uh the
Predator it is all right it is all right
uh I could take it or leave it the one
with the Indians was a little bit
better prey prey yeah the one that was
on Hulu a little bit better I actually
liked that one the only thing I didn't
like about that one is it didn't quite
feel authentic those people really
didn't didn't really look like Native
Americans to me they they looked too C A
lot of them were but yeah they should
have dirtied them up they looked too
clean they looked too modern with modern
hair and they didn't look like people
that were actually surviving in the
wilderness they would look a lot harder
the those people look like they were
middle middle class people from Suburbia
what they look like well they probably
are because they're actors you know
right Sebastian says uh Rob botin or
Dean cundy are you asking me who did the
effects on the thing or which one I like
better because that's going to be Rob
botin all day long Dean C is good too
though um let's see Zach says a movie
that always impressed me for its um vlx
was the first Silent Hill movie yeah the
effects in that were really good and I I
don't [__] on CGI I'm not one of those
cranky old [__] that's just
kind of like oh everything new sucks and
it's like I don't want to be like that
but I will say that if you have if you
made a movie in the
1990s um with CGI with the with the
exception of Jurassic Park which still
looks great um you know and you watch it
nowadays that CGI is going to look like
ass yeah that's just the nature of the
Beast um but practical effects if
they're done well the first time they
don't age yeah because that's there and
somebody made that look at Jurassic
Park some of the best CGI you'll find
right there man 1993 that [__] thing
came out and it still looks good it's CG
but it's it looks good it still looks
good so it can be done yeah I would just
I prefer CGI to be used for just like
backgrounds or erase Footprints erase
footprint like [__] like that like
little [__] you know what I
mean Sebastian said the thing couldn't
have been mccre what do you say there
mccre wasn't the thing unless they were
at war with each other yeah mccre wasn't
the thing neither was Child's I don't
think child's was the thing either no
because he's got an earring in yeah he's
got an earring and I thought they pretty
much showed that yeah they showed the
earring glimmer but they never really
[__] that carp was
slick I got to pee you see the earring
clean but they don't make it important
yeah you have to figure it out for
yourself that the thing can't replicate
an
earring and this in in 2011 they would
they they they spilled it out they can't
it can't replicate earrings and it can't
replicate replicate
fillings
so no child's was was a human
too but what's being implied
at the end of the first
thing what's implied is that mccre
kills um Childs and roast him with the
flamethrower
because remember in the beginning of the
movie mccre is playing chess with the
computer and he loses so he takes glass
takes a glass of whiskey on the rocks
and pours it into the into the computer
and shorts it out and go and calls it a
che cheating
[__] well they're just trying to let
you know that mccre is not a guy that
plays by the rules he will cheat and
call other people a
cheater okay he's kind yeah I like that
it was kind of like a nice bit of
foreshadowing yeah yeah well when Childs
comes down to to uh to say yeah I got
lost in the snow you know what do we do
now fing then mccre goes I don't know
let's just wait and see and he hands him
the whiskey and child's drinks the
whiskey all right and that's I think
that was the time you see the
earring but then they pan back over
to
mccre and mccre doesn't I don't think he
noticed the earring and then that's it
that's see bom boom bo so my take on it
is that it was here here's cheating
[__] and then he was GNA
[__] hit him with the flamethrower CU
why would you take the chance you're
both going to die anyway
yeah I mean I think they had both like
um kind of gotten to that point and if
you freeze to death when the rescue
party comes you're going to revive the
thing yeah so it wouldn't surprise me if
mccre
fried pretty pretty sure MCC fried
Childs and then probably
himself because that's kind of I'm it's
kind of the responsible thing to do like
I said you don't want the thing getting
out yeah but mccre was a knucklehead he
was a man of his time
all right he's running around blowing
the thing up with [__] Dynamite
blowing little pieces of that [__]
everywhere that's kind of freezing out
in the [__] snow I was like those are
going to wake back up dude yeah he's
spreading it he's spreading spre it
spreading the infection around right
trying to get rid of it I mean he didn't
know that's something a dude that grew
up in the 70s would do yeah it's like
let's just blow it up blow that [__] up
cuz that's what kind of d m he was
right well like I said's perfect for
that man his defense like I said they
had never dealt with anything like this
like an organism like they didn't know
necessarily I'm imagining that like
later on after they realized that like
every little piece of it was its own
little thing and could go off and do its
own [__] they were probably like oh man
we like blew it up and there's pieces of
it all over the place so it's like it
probably escaped you like and that's
what I mean if that was a real organism
you'd never be able to contain it ever
if like the smallest little piece of it
that broke off could go do its own [__]
and like end up replicating something
else later on you could never you never
fight that when The Outpost doesn't make
regular radio checks they're going to go
down there to see The Outpost it's going
to be [__] cooked and they're going
to [__] find little pieces of things
and bring and try to bring bodies back
that are [__] alien bodies Frozen
because they they left a lot of those
behind yep and uh it'll get out they'll
take all that stuff back to warm climate
and it'll thaw out and kill people so
it's it's the Earth is [__] pretty
much yeah it's [__] yeah I mean and I
and I love they didn't save [__] they
just delayed love that they never made a
sequel to that either because the thing
2011 that's a prequel that's about the
Norwegian Camp yeah so and I like that
but I like that they just never could
they were just like yep that's if you
make a sequel It's going to be they go
down there and they find them [__]
bodies and they start taking them back
and they find all this weird biomatter
and take it back and then then affects
everybody and it's in a warm climate now
and it's going to be out of control
going to be like World War Z except it's
[__] that'd be a good movie but
humans couldn't win no no yeah it would
have to have like a super bleak
yeah you'd have three years of fighting
it and you you you just each year harder
and harder because there' be less people
you would fail yeah
um I mean pretty much yeah and I said
that in my video I said if that was a
real moner like you would have no way to
defeat it no way you would we' be hoes
big time and uh that's what a superior
biological life form would be
like there'd be no defeating it John gor
said um assume he's talking about the
thing gave a sense of Doom right off the
bat like the guys were already breaking
down and the winter already started and
I argued in my video that I posted
earlier I think that the thing might
have one of my favorite opening
sequences of any movie ever I love that
sequence like the Norwegian guy and
they're like shooting at the dog because
it pulls you right in what the [__] is
going on like why are you shooting at a
dog that's like such a crazy yeah
there's no subtitles and then and what
he says Americans don't know Norwegian
and he's and he says that is not a dog
not a dog it's not a dog you idiot but
they don't know what he's saying you
can't understand what he's saying they
like why you shooting at a dog you [__]
face which is what anybody would think
that's why it's so great that's why it's
so great I think that's one of the best
opening sequences like in cinema history
seriously it's so good it just like
pulls you right in because you're just
like oh my god what the [__] is going on
here
um yeah JN gor said it also establishes
that these dudes on this Arctic Base
have a problem with feminized
civilization and women yeah kind of I
like liked that it was all men though I
didn't mind that they that there was um
you know women in the second one because
you know whatever how do it established
they have any problem with that that's
just that was normal guys at the time
yeah that's well yeah yeah there wasn't
anything about that and he said he goes
Colonel Curts pretty pretty quick he
does yeah but like I said you don't it's
an alien you wouldn't necessarily
understand that it could I mean you
would think oh it's just an animal and
you can just blow it up I mean that
kills pretty much anything on earth
right so you wouldn't understand that
it's just kind of like a little pieces
of it could
replicate yeah um so you know you can't
blame them completely they were just out
of their depth I don't know how old you
are but even when I was coming up in the
military it was the outp one of the
Outpost I was on op 311 it was only six
men and it's all men we were in on a
desert island in the Gulf of akaba the
whole Army infantry was just just men so
for four years I just saw just
men that's what they're
doing being on a research station up
there just in that era in that era would
have been all men it'd be like working
on a damn oil rig but they'd probably be
there for a year long six months or one
year rotations probably year on year off
they probably other teams taking their
places yeah they have guys that lived
like that their whole lives yeah some of
them at se similar how guy C
lives Ian said wasn't he kind of implied
to be a war vet
Kurt Russell's character yeah yeah he's
he's a chopper pilot from Vietnam yeah
that's right they did say that didn't
they well because he's only yeah he's
only just yeah he's wearing army stuff
yeah and uh McCree uh uh child is
wearing army stuff too he's wearing an
army um black sweater so he's probably
also Army the other guys like you know
Windows he seems to be Navy the
communicator I think he's wearing Navy
stuff so they're exmilitary a lot of
them and then the uh that one scientist
the one one that was doing the
uh one that was helping
um he had an earring in his ear mhm he's
an old guy with an earring in his ear in
that era the only men that wore earrings
in their ear were merchant marines and
guys that had crossed the equator and
they put that earring
in so you're talking about men of the
sea and Military guys yeah which like I
said I think that was one of the things
that makes that movie so good is you got
to be hardened to long period perod of
time of [__] Solitude and just being
around dudes and learning how to live
with other people and being in this
place that you can't really being in a
place you can't do anything I did it man
you can't really get anywhere you're
like in the middle of that was
Antarctica right Antarctica Antarctica
yeah the Bas yeah you had to deal with
uh
isolation and you but you got to be in a
tight group you can't turn on one
another which what happened but see
that's what made this movie so great is
that these dudes you know you presume up
until this point had had to rely on each
other for Survival cuz you would and now
it's like you don't know if this dude is
who you think it is anymore so it's like
now everybody's just like I don't trust
you you don't trust anybody it's like
the whole [__] [__] breaks down yeah
because that whole unit is based on that
type of cohesion sure and when that got
attacked that's it yeah every man for
himself on the [__] bottom of the
Earth yeah no one there to save you yeah
that's what makes that movie so scary to
me that's what makes it such a great
horror movie no cell phones this is
another era yep yeah that's I'm just
same help help was weeks away and even
if you could get to somebody that's like
they couldn't get there and the only
thing that would come would be a
helicopter which is going to only have a
couple guys on it yeah it's like what
are they what can they do for you like I
said they probably just spread the thing
further yeah Danny also says burnt
offerings and American Werewolf in Paris
should get theater re-releases with
touched up werewolf CGI and added old
mother ghost CGI for burn off Franks
just like the Star Wars
I don't know if I agree with that or not
cuz look I love burnt offerings that's
one of my favorite movies of the 70s one
of my favorite Haunted House movies of
all time book is great too um I think it
was better that they just left it
ambiguous that you don't ever
see the old lady because as I've said
before I think we talked about this
before but I don't think and at least
according to the book I was under the
impression that the mother Mrs allardice
or mother allardice didn't exist at
least not in a human form I thought she
was like the essence of the house so she
wasn't a person you know what I mean she
was like some kind of weird being or I
didn't even know if I'd go that far I
think she's just like a
force so because in the book I think um
you know she opens the
door and there's just like a bright like
a white light she doesn't see anything
you know what I mean so I think that
it's better to leave it like that
because like I said I think the house in
that was implied to be a
living entity or like a living organism
of some kind that fed off human
energy so it didn't have to have it
didn't have to have a human component
but that was just kind of like the face
like I said and I think I made this
comparison before it's almost kind of
like when you see the movie The Shining
you know you see Lloyd the bartender who
is kind of like he's not a
person but that's just how Jack
Nicholson's character that's how
Torrance is seeing him like he's just
seeing like the hotel being personified
like in this one person but that's not a
real person so I think it's kind of like
the same thing with burnt offerings I
think the house is a living organism you
know and it doesn't have so the mom
isn't a real person either all right so
are you ready to shut it down shut it
down shut it on down all right so we're
GNA wrap up this discussion because it's
getting kind of past 9:00 I guess and um
hopefully I might do a stream tomorrow
I'll see I did watch um the Lim house
Golem today which somebody recommended
to me which is actually really good so
if I get that together I might do it
tomorrow or I might do it Thursday we'll
see but Wednesday night uh we're going
to do our show and this is actually kind
of a cool case somebody recommended
recommended doing this like a long time
ago and it finally won like in the polls
this is um it was a murder case back in
the early 20th century that um Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle was involved in it
was a murder case and there was a guy
named Oscar Slater who was um wrongfully
convicted of it and spent a long time in
jail uh so we're going to talk about
that on the show on Wednesday night it
should be really interesting like I said
because it's a really interesting case
so hopefully you guys can all drop by
for that uh so thanks for dropping by
and hanging out with us this evening and
we'll see you guys again on Wednesday
night
good night